thanks for watching this video from
spectator TV if you enjoy what we do
here do subscribe to our YouTube channel
just click the Subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and tap the Bell
icon so you never miss a video
[Music]
first up chunks being indicted again
before this year no sitting or former
president had ever been inducted and
this isn't even Donald Trump's first
legal troubles but will any of it really
impact his chances of re-election I'm
joined by Angie Neil
Andrew welcome back to spectator TV it's
great to have you
back
Andrew I had a moment of deja vu earlier
this week when I saw the headline Trump
indicted come back to Markov again so
for viewers who've lost track Like Me
who've lost track of the amount of legal
cases against Donald Trump he just
update us on what this latest one is
about
right he says quickly looking at his
notes
um well he is now indicted on 91
accounts I'll say that again
accounts he's been indicted and in four
broad indictments uh the original one is
the first in chronological order was to
do with the hush money that he paid uh a
porn star uh or as a registered opinion
where he paid the money they're calling
it uh I must say now that's even small
beer compared to what has come since and
then we've had um special prosecutor
Smith bring two cards against him one is
his Mr Trump's handling of the
classified documents particularly of
Mara Lago and the efforts he made really
not to hand them back which is doing him
more damage than the act of taking them
in the first place then of course is the
third broader one about his behavior in
the run-up to January the 6th and post
uh what he regarded as the stolen
election and of course the riot that
broke kind of in Capitol Hill that day
and his role in that and then of course
this latest one now these first three uh
the Smith ones are federal this one in
Georgia this week is State that's not
it's not federal but this is to do with
the specific efforts he took to try and
get those responsible for the count in
Georgia
uh to do as he wanted he lost Georgia by
fewer than 12 000 votes there's a famous
tape call when he speaks to the
Republican uh local official there local
politician uh the Secretary of State I
believe he was at the time you know for
for Georgia saying you just need to find
me 11
000 and several hundred bullets and I'll
be fine so that is all that plus fake
electors leading on people to change
their mind do different things this one
is interesting I always thought the
Georgia one might be the most important
of all
because
that tape alone is pretty hard to
explain he's clearly urging the local
official to find 12 000 votes somewhere
I just want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state you should want
to have an accurate election
and you're a Republican
we believe but we do have an accurate
election no I know you don't no no you
don't you don't have you don't have not
even close but also because this is a
state rap he's up against
if he loses he cannot pardon himself if
he becomes president again presidents
can't do that they can pardon themselves
at least we think they can for a federal
rap they can't pardon themselves for a
state rap uh what he's been accused of
which is under the Reichel laws which
are the racketeering laws which go back
to 1970 and this is a Georgia version of
the federal racketeering laws which
basically killed the Italian mafia in
the United States basically destroyed
the Italian mafia they're using that
against them as they've broadened it out
as well that carries a minimum of a
five-year sentence so there's no plea
bargaining there there's no uh probation
it's a minimum five-year sentence to do
that
and even the governor of Georgia cannot
pardon him so even a friendly Republican
couldn't pardon him so in many ways
that's the more dangerous one but you
add them all up the 91 indictments in
four separate cases which means that
how much time he'll spend on the
campaign Trail and how much time he'll
spend in the courtroom is a moot point I
mean there just aren't enough hours in
the day to do both yes to say so he'll
be going to trial for these cases next
year but in the longer term we might
have a president of America or former
president or president if he wins again
being in jail could that happen
yes it could happen I mean he could run
for president in jail it's happened
before he run the country from jail
well yeah it has happened before there
was a a American Socialist called Eugene
Debs
um he's what today we'd call a peace
Nick he was uh against the draft the
conscription in World War One
um President Wilson basically Adam
arrested uh during the water was the end
of the war and he was stuck in a federal
penitentiary interestingly he was um but
tried under the then new Espionage Act
um which covers more than Espionage and
one of uh special prosecutors Smith's
cases against them is under that 19
under against Mr Trump is under that
1917 Espionage too so the same piece of
legislation affected Eugene Debs it put
him in the in the slammer and is now
being used against Mr Trump now that was
in the run-up to the 1920 election where
Woodrow Wilson couldn't run uh that
didn't run again he'd had a stroke his
wife had been running the country so the
Republican candidate was Warren Harding
Eugene Debs ran from jail from a federal
penitentiary and he got about a million
votes which was a little better than one
of the previous elections when he had
run so you could do it I think maybe a
little harder today because he didn't
win either Harding won by pretty much on
one side but you could see some of it
being run I think the from jail the
though I don't think the trials are
going to happen quick enough for that to
happen
uh you know the the special prosecutor
Smith has said he wants one of his cases
to begin on January the second which
would be two weeks before the Iowa
caucus which is the kickoff of the
Republican uh primary season uh good
luck with that the woman is reading the
case against uh Mr Trump in Georgia she
says she wants it within six months for
hers to begin well she's taken two and a
half years to get here the 98 page
document she's produced doesn't really
tell us anything we didn't know about
the behavior of Mr Trump and his
acolytes already and she is indicted 18
other co-conspiracies including Rudy
Giuliani and uh that somewhat mad woman
Sydney Powell the one that said the
Kraken wakes I mean if anybody is ever a
sandwich short of a picnic it's her
um and of course Mr Meadows who was his
chief of staff there is no way uh all of
that is going to be done in uh six
months time ready to go to trial so I
suspect more likely some of them I think
we'll probably get through the Iowa
caucus and then the New Hampshire
primary which is a couple of weeks later
to the end of January I think they will
both happen without any of the trials
happening Cindy I think there will be
some pre-trial hearings there'll be some
motions before the court you know
lawyers who see this as a dripping roast
they'll have their snouts on the trough
to get as big a fees as they can from
everybody involved but I don't think any
trial is going to begin it may have
begun by super Tuesday which is in March
but probably not before then but Andrew
what does all of this mean for Trump's
campaign and its possibility of success
because on the one hand as you say
there's literally not enough hours and I
think they're spending a lot of campaign
Finance on the lawyers as well on the
other hand it seems like if you believe
that this is a political Witch Hunt
against Trump You're simply going to
believe it even more with every single
method of lawfare a some have called it
that comes up so what do you think well
you're right a big chunk of the campaign
finance that Mr Trump has been raising
is going on legal fees and I suspect
that percentage will rise as we get
towards the trials uh and the law is
then spending you really start to rack
up legal fees when you get into court or
in the lead up to court that's when the
real money is when these lawyers aren't
billed by the hour and uh well I mean I
think we're in the wrong business indeed
I think we should quickly get a legal
education and start building but we are
um so it's it's going to be hugely
expensive
now what it's done so far is
Consolidated his base I mean he did joke
a couple of weeks ago I just need one
more indictment and I'll be unbeatable
in the Republican the race of the
Republican nomination well he's got his
indictment and he does look unbeatable I
must say he does look unbeatable for the
Republican nomination uh all these
indictments seem just to reinforce the
base that what he calls the Deep state
is out to get him and he says they're
coming from me now but if we don't win
this they're coming for you he says to
his base and they lap it up and it's
been a disaster for the other candidates
the um DeSantis campaign governor of
Florida thought to be the only real
Challenger to Mr Trump his campaign as a
Messner going nowhere he's fired some
people he's having to reboot it it also
Cindy puts them in a the the people who
would challenge Trump
it puts them in a really difficult
situation because it means people like
you and me are some questions such as
well was the election stolen uh is it
right that Mr Trump should face all
these indictments did he do anything
wrong does he deserve to be tried under
the racketeering laws for a criminal
conspiracy and they're terrified of
these questions because they're
terrified of saying anything that will
annoy the Trump base so as things stand
at the moment he is the Republican
candidate uh that's just the way it is
the unforeseen things can happen which
by definition we don't know but at the
moment he is the Republican candidate
now the conventional wisdom is yes yes
all this gets under the Republican
nomination again
but it is putting off Suburban voters it
is particularly putting off middle-class
Suburban women
who he got in 2016 and lost in 2020 and
none of this none of this is doing a
many favors come the general election
that's the conventional wisdom I think
there's a lot to it
I would simply put two markers on the
ground just to keep an eye on Cindy so
far and in a way I share that
conventional wisdom too the famous
soccer moms as they call them in America
um are not uh I'm not going to I'm not
going to like what Trump has been up to
with the fake election or January the
sixth or whatever
but there's no sign yet in the polls
that this is playing to Mr Biden's
Advantage because you would think all
right it's getting the Republican
nomination but Biden's lead in a
notional poll Trump versus of which
there is a lot of polling been done on
that now surely Biden will be moving
further and further ahead there is no
sign of that in the poll Cindy all the
signs are is that they're nip and Tuck
they're around 44 they're both within
the margin of error uh there it is too
close to coal in these poles at the
moment so that's something to keep an
eye on and kind of in a way makes you
question the conventional wisdom second
thing I would look for is I'm still not
in any doubt you will lose a lot of
middle-class Suburban votes he he is
doing nothing he's consolidating his
base but he's doing nothing to win back
the people he that voted for him in 2016
but he lost in 2020 that's not happening
however
there are signs that an increasing
number of working class Hispanic voters
are moving his way are moving the
Republican way and therefore moving his
way too and although there aren't as
many of them around us there are white
Suburban middle class women
some of what he's not getting back could
be made up for and remember if you take
the by these Hispanic voters who are
becoming more and more Republican over
the years you know that the house
recently elected his first ever
mexican-born Congressman actually a
woman and a republican from a district
that borders Texas with Mexico so that
is going on as we speak and that could
make a difference that that could help
counteract the fact that he's not
getting that moderate white Suburban
vote back again
[Music]
thank you